why do my palms get sweaty when i watch
videos of people climbing up cranes and
stuff like that you know the ones that i
mean the guy's got a gopro is a dude
called james kingston from the uk that's
a psychopath he goes up to the highest
towers of dubai
illegally in the middle of the night and
then i watch it on a screen it's only
this big
and
i get this visceral response yeah well
two things first of all i i can relate
you know i saw the free solo movie with
alex honold and you know he lives
and it's still scary to watch right you
actually know the outcome at the
beginning they sort of make it clear
that he manages to do this
and
you're it's still terrifying and i think
it's for the same reason that those
youtube videos are terrifying
which is
that we are so visual as animals we are
so visual i mean
rodents even a lot of carnivore
predators are extremely olfactory smell
driven
humans are incredibly visual i mean more
than 40 of the human brain has something
to do with vision visual navigation eye
movements um
visual perception color perception face
perception we have dedicated areas of
the brain that are just for perceiving
human faces and these micro expressions
of human faces so so highly evolved for
us
when we see
depth of field
that's not
parallel to the ground
it is terrifying with good reason
because
you know what's the universal force that
we all experience from the time we're
born is gravity the first thing you
learn is that things fall down not up
right they you know it's it's like the
the fundamental rule that we come into
the world with it's like
day one even though the baby is kind of
flopping around like a potato but can't
even hold its head up the eyes are often
you know the ocular muscles of the eyes
are often not very good so babies will
kind of eyes are rolling back in their
head that generally corrects itself
over the next few weeks or so
but the feeling of gravity of them you
know if they feel like they're being
dropped even the tiniest bit
right they will go wide-eyed so there's
a built-in vestibulo ocular reflex so
when you see depth of field in the
direction of the gravitational pull
you actually get a little bit of
activity in your cerebellum which
literally means mini brain a little area
of the brain in the back that actually
looks like a little mini brain if you
were looking at the brain and that area
of the brain is responsible for all the
reflexes associated with the falling
reflex it does a lot of other things too
so when you see that depth of field in
the direction of gravity
there you have a little micro activity
in your brain that you might fall
if you've ever been to a tall bridge or
a dam and you go to the edge and you
know people love to play with this
there's that also that tower in toronto
they have that big um
tower well the big no the big um the big
tower i forget what it is maybe it's in
calgary goodness canadians are gonna
hate me okay i love canadians but for
some reason i can't remember this they
have one of those glass floors there
where you can walk and it's terrifying
and you know you're not going to fall
through it right there they tell you
you're not going to fall through it but
it's terrifying
because your
body and brain are preparing for this
immense fall so when you see this in
video it's the same thing i always say a
picture is worth a thousand words but a
video is worth 10 million pictures i
mean this is the reason why we're so
drawn to things like instagram scrolling
it's like text text
video you know or the the enormous
popularity of tick tock it's video now
the enormous popularity of twitter still
escapes me because that's a different
different sort of cultural gravitational
pull but video and in particular action
that gets us in a kind of a primitive
mode
that is an extremely alluring visual
image what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace